descending deep below the Ukrainian
Capital these escalators carry crowds of
commuters to kiev's Golden Gate Metro
station about 90 meters Underground
it's below freezing at street level down
here it's even colder but people don't
mind the temperature because at least
it's safe
there's an air raid alert as we film so
young and old Gather in the station
until it's lifted
we've come down here because there's a
threat in the center of the city we
always come down here
sure I'm worried I hope all this madness
will come to an end and that the
Russians will experience everything
we've lived through
fewer people come down now than in the
early days of the war when the city was
encircled by Russian forces and
thousands lived underground for weeks
platforms and trains became makeshift
camps crammed with people and their pets
and the few belongings they could carry
was on night shift at lukanyevska Metro
station when the first explosion struck
my friend called me at 5am and said the
war has started I couldn't believe it
they be heard the sirens and people
started to run to the metro to ask for
shelter there were so many people and
they were scared
she tells me how she lived in the
station for two months helping organize
food and sanitation for the crowds of
terrified people
as the head of the station I couldn't
leave those people behind because I knew
they needed my help and when I saw the
fear in their eyes I could not leave
one of the challenges for those running
Keys Metro System but also systems
across the country over the past year
was how to keep people safe whilst also
keeping the trains running
now about half a million people ride
these trains Every Day determined to
keep life as normal as possible as up
above the war grinds on
I believe everything will be fine if
there are any future attacks we'll be
ready we feel positive
these stations that were once tourist
hot spots are now places of refuge and
symbols of Ukraine's resilience
Alexi O'Brien Al Jazeera Kiev